living your wine means that when we make
decisions we are conscientious about
having our y front-and-center that we
consider whether we are helping bring
our Y to life at or advancing our wire
or not look we can always make the
decision not to but I would rather do
that consciously and know why we're
choosing to do it it's like living a
healthy lifestyle and choosing to eat
chocolate cake it's totally fine but you
do with eyes wide open knowing that you
have to you know work out a little more
over the weekend or you just don't do it
that often so it's the same thing Y
provides that that focus and direction
and and so we can live with purpose on
purpose
[Music]